bonsoir et bienvenue pour le journal de
la rédaction édition chargé ce soir je
vous propose de découvrir dès à présent
les titres de ce 10 décembre des
filières pourraient disparaître au lycée
17 mar à maurepas les élèves se sont
rassemblés à versailles devant le
rectorat pour obtenir des explications
l'édition 2014 du téléthon déjà dans les
têtes les organisateurs alors que cette
année des records ont été battus sur le
terrain dans les yvelines et des clips
théâtre propose deux spectacles welcome
abord la culture pour faire disparaître
la discrimination sur le marché du
travail et dans la vie quotidienne
mélanie lemoine la co directrice de la
compagnie et julien kara juriste à la
maison du droit et de la justice seront
les invités du 7-8 l'actus ce soir
l'image du jour allait consacrer au
nucléaire la délégation yvelinoise de la
société d'énergie nucléaire s'est réuni
ce matin l'occasion de faire un point
sur le nucléaire dans le département il
n'y a pas de centrale pourtant les
activités de recherche de contrôle
d'ingénierie ou encore de transport de
combustible génère de l'emploi
les membres ont notamment rappelé leur
volonté de maintenir le socle du
nucléaire tout en soutenant le
développement les énergies renouvelables
le nucléaire est une contribution très
importante dans l'est dans les yvelines
puisque l'industrie nucléaire représente
1800 emplois directs répartis entre la
production d'électricité du grès aussi
le médical les 1800 personnes sont
réparties sur quatre pôles importants le
pôle le plus important c'est sur 50 ans
en yvelines où il ya eu une activité
très très forte depuis une trentaine
d'années sur le nucléaire
nous avons également chatou dans les
yvelines bien sûr le vésinet est
également villacoublay éducation la
filière sciences et technologies de
management de la gestion du lycée 17 mar
à maurepas est en péril une soixantaine
d'élèves
elle s'est déplacée devant le rectorat
de versailles pour protester contre un
projet de fermeture de cette section une
délégation de professeurs de parents et
d'élèves a été reçue ce midi par le
recteur yolaine 13 et patrick jacques de
dixmude
les lycéens de l'établissement 17 mar à
maurepas sont en colère la filière
sciences et technologies de management
de la gestion dite stm g pourrait être
supprimée dès la rentrée prochaine pour
les premières et dès 2015 pour les
terminales une série alternative aux
bacs généraux qui existe depuis 40 ans
le lycée ou un nouveau là en défendent
la mixité des filières au lycée 17 mars
c'est l'identité du lycée depuis
l'origine nous voulons donner la chance
à tous les élèves de réussir et c'est
une voie technologique qui est une voie
de réussite pour des élèves qui qui qui
qui ont des difficultés peut-être s'en
suivre en section générale et qui
s'épanouissent dans ses réer qui
réussissent très bien si nous fermons
cette filière ça veut dire plus
possibilité pour nos élèves de
poursuivre s'en mord pas donc ça veut
dire des déplacements dans d'autres
communes etc
et voilà il refuse de toute façon de
partir à les raisons évoquées par le
recteur une baisse des effectifs sur les
établissements environnants avec 80
places vacantes cette année au lycée 17
mars
on compte 23 élèves de première et 35
élèves de terminale dans la section est
et m g
c'est moins que les années précédentes
pour autant d'après les élèves
cette filière avec un taux de réussite
de 85 % l'année dernière est toujours
aussi appréciée est importante pour le
lycée on espère tous garder notre
filière dans ce dans ce lycée parce que
c'est une filière très demandée est très
reconnu dans le bassin qui regroupe neuf
lycées pour la mixité sociale il faut
qu'il y à des personnes issues de
plusieurs filières de plusieurs animaux
sociaux
donc ces voix-là important aussi c'est
une des raisons pour laquelle il est
important de laisser la vitesse une
pétition a été lancée plus de 500
signatures ont déjà été recueillies
contacté à plusieurs reprises le
rectorat n'a pas répondu à nos
sollicitations
dans le cadre du plan de lutte contre
les discriminations et pour l'égalité la
compagnie déclic théâtre a créé où elle
comme à bord spectacle présenté aux
collégiens ou clichés et idées reçues
provoc mais surtout éveiller les
consciences
aurélia de 8,6 et j'en attends willeman
pour les images nous vous souhaitons un
agréable voyage à bord du conformer à
welcome l'abord du confort mien la
traversée desservira l'archipel des
cloisons où se trouvent les îles
ben venus des d'aaron des crevards ou
encore des dollars que vous soyez noir
blanc jeune riche ou pauvre
chacun y trouvera ainsi sa place enfin
il s'agit surtout de ce que la compagnie
déclic théâtre veut dénoncer avec humour
grâce à cet outil théâtrale où elle
comme à bord spectacle pour les
scolaires créer en 2012 par quatre
comédiens de la compagnie s'inscrit dans
le cadre du plan de lutte contre la
discrimination pour l'égalité c'était
vraiment pour pour répondre à une
demande par rapport aux établissements
scolaires du coup on a été observée dans
plusieurs écoles on a récupéré pas mal
de deux témoignent à la fois d'élèves de
professeurs et puis ensuite on sait on
s'est vraiment mis tous les quatre et on
s'est mis à écrire et à réunir un peu
trop l'autriche et qu'on avait amassé
est homosexuel j'aurais dû m'en douter
j'avais trouvé un tee shirt rose de lady
gaga dans sa lessive objectif c'est ça
c'est d'éveiller les consciences et de
se dire que si on a des discussions sur
la discrimination le sexisme
enfin tôt peut-être qu'on retarde un
petit peu la pression de la société cas
ce que c'était on rassure les gens
présenté aujourd'hui aux élèves du
collège youri-gagarine de trappes
le spectacle est suivi d'un débat avec
un juriste une méthode pour laisser
s'exprimer les clichés et les préjugés
j'essaye après de ramener un spectacle
au sujet des discriminations de mon
devoir avec eux des définitions
importante des mots stéréotypes des
clichés de leur faire comprendre un peu
les mécanismes de mise en place de des
discriminations comment on peut arriver
soit mais m ou bien victimes ou bien
auteur d'une discrimination
j'ai appris qu'il faut pas discriminer
les gens ci interdit par la loi
il faut avoir
de respect par exemple j'ai un copain
des fois je le traite a fait de grosses
de traiter sur le physique mais pour
rigoler mais il aimait pas trop alors je
pense que je vais arrêter comme ça les
gens quand ils vont traiter les autres
je pourrais dire où est la
discrimination ça le message semble être
bien passé
le spectacle se produira dans d'autres
lieux à la demande des établissements
scolaires et pour parler de ce spectacle
mélanie lemoine la codirectrice de
déclic théâtre et julien kara juristes
sont en plateau ce soir bonsoir à tous
les deux on vous a vu dans ce reportage
mélanie lemoine on est dans le coeur du
travail de déclic là on utiliser la
culture le théâtre comme un outil sur un
sujet très sérieux très sensible oui
bien sûr ça fait partie vraiment de nous
nos missions ils nous envient à travers
tous les spectacles qu'on défend donc
oui en plus ce qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est que c'est un spectacle
qu'on a qu'on a écrit en collaboration
avec des professeurs et du coup c'est
vraiment faire remonter la parole est le
terrain sur la scène avec notre savoir
faire qui est de décaler et de mettre un
peu d'humour là dedans et ça débloque la
parole justement des élèves on en a
entendu quelques uns tout à l'heure et
agir prendre conscience aussi avec leurs
propres mots mais c'est plus facile
d'engager la discussion avec je pense
que ça débloque vraiment faim en tout
cas nous quand on joue on se rend compte
que les réactions sont sont assez fortes
c'est un spectacle quand même qui
bouscule un peu qui va un peu on l'a vu
dans les images c'est quand même ça va
un peu loin et on l'entend nous vraiment
quand on est sur scène des réactions
très fortes
après je vous dirais que peut-être c'est
pas forcément pour ça que que la parole
est débloqué tout de suite quoi voilà
bien le travail qui est fait ensuite
après lorsque vous intervenez pour les
âmes ou d amener à parler à s'exprimer
sur des sujets qui les concernent aussi
la discrimination concerne tommy wiseau
on essaie de se rapprocher de leur vie
du quotidien parce que voilà
la vie de ces collégiens elles se
passent pas simplement au collège mais
aussi dans la rue en famille et
sujet des discriminations que les
touches et à n'importe quel moment de
leur vie
plus tard dans leur carrière
professionnelle ou même dès maintenant
parce que là on touchait des 3e et en
est en pleine période de stage
d'observation pour les 3e et on a lu un
témoin notamment qui nous a exposé qu'il
avait été victime de discrimination
lorsqu'il a fait une demande de stage
auquel quel type de discrimination
justement quelle est la réalité de la
discrimination c'est un mot qui est on
l'a entendu les élèves ont pris
conscience aussi c'est puni il ya des
lois qui existent la discrimination
c'est englobe quelle réalité alors les
sept plutôt des chiffres qui augmente
mais en même temps le problème c'est que
les jeux la plupart des gens n'en font
rarement par les principaux critères de
discrimination qu'on retrouve qui sont
malheureusement appliquée c'est le
critère d origine pour empêcher l'accès
à un emploi ou un logement par exemple
ensuite vous retrouvez le sexe donc le
rapport figard sont vos hommes femmes et
dans le monde du travail aujourd'hui en
france y encore beaucoup de choses à
faire pour savoir que sur qualification
égale métier égal les femmes peuvent
toucher jusqu'à 27% de moins au niveau
du salaire par rapport à un homme est
ensuite vous retrouver le critère de
l'âge puisque deux tranches d'âge sont
victimes aujourd'hui discrimination à la
fois les jeunes les 18 25 et les
personnes de 50 ans et plus la façon de
faire de déclic la meilleure des façons
justement pour aborder ce sujet avec les
plus jeunes c'est une ancienne route
c'est un molière qui disait corriger les
moeurs par le rire donc ce n'est pas une
idée nouvelle
on
rien inventé si ce n'est un spectacle et
l'idée d'essayer de connecter des
services différents parcours ce n'est
justement c'est de connecter aux
différents services de travailler avec
un juriste et que la sf
ça fait quand même longtemps que l'on
travaille nous enfin depuis le début
d'ailleurs 2 du plan de lutte contre les
discriminations et pour l'égalité on
travaille nous là dedans
donc je pense que depuis le début en
fait on travaille quasiment avec la
maison de la justice sur un an et un
certain temps et puis un tir que anne
l'intérieur s'est fait naturellement et
autour de huy le projet comment
commencer monte aussi le spectacle parce
qu'il faut viser juste pour ce spectacle
et toucher directement les problèmes
vous allez travailler ensemble pour
élaborer ce spectacle va on a surtout
travaillé avec les professeurs du lycée
mathis qui nous ont fait vraiment faim
je me souviens d'une réunion qui était
sidérant tous unis nous faisait remonter
ce qui se passait vraiment dans les
classes c'est à dire vraiment des des
classes qui sont complètement donc il ya
les blancs d'un côté les noirs de
l'autre les nains il raconté qu'il y
avait eu 1 1 qui avait été mal traité de
tous les noms que c'était pas possible
que les filles surtout avait des
discours terrible 10 ans madame toute
façon je vais pas faire d'études parce
que je vais me marier donc ça sert à
rien enfin des choses quand même assez
violent donc nous on s'en est emparé
très fort parce que ça nous a vraiment
faim ça nous a promu et que c'est un
sujet sur lequel on travaille depuis
longtemps on a commencé à travailler
dans les entreprises avec le spectacle à
tête de l'emploi il y a
quelques années maintenant et donc oui
nous on sent néons c'en est vraiment
emparer puis je pense que c'était
important que ce soient toujours suivis
de débats
on peut pas livrer ce spectacle comme ça
et puis c'est vachement important qu'il
y ait vraiment un juriste qui viennent
expliqué qu' il ya des lois et que c'est
important et respecté
et en plus parce que je trouve important
pardon c'est aussi qu' ils comprennent
bien la différence entre le racisme et
la discrimination ils sont quand même
assez
tout le monde sait ce que c'est le
racisme et ils ont ça on assez forts ils
se sentent souvent dans les lits dans
les collèges dans lesquelles ont été ils
savent très bien ce que c'est mais ils
se rendent pas forcément compte que eux
mêmes sont porteurs de discrimination et
ils font pas forcément la différence et
je trouve que ça on ça c'est vraiment
intéressant
la quel moment ça devient une
discrimination véritablement parce que
l'on monte un des élèves tout à l'heure
il évoqué voilà embêter un petit peu
taquiner son son camarade que ce soit
sur des problèmes de poids de taille aux
autres à quel moment ça franchi la ligne
la barrière il faut revenir sur la
définition simple peut-être la
discrimination le fait d'écarter une ou
plusieurs personnes
la distinguée en fonction justement de
critères plus ou moins apparent des
critères qui sont interdits par la loi
alors maintenant la loi prévoit 19
critères de discrimination je pourrai
pas tout cela et dans des domaines comme
refuser l'accès à un emploi refuser
l'accès à un service public
refuser l'accès à l'éducation par
exemple et donc voilà la situation avec
à partir de quel moment à elne et à
partir du moment où vous êtes écarté
d'un service d'un travail d'une
administration d'un emploi parce que sur
la base d'un critère comme ça interdit
par la loi je voudrais juste rappeler
puisqu'on parle de discrimination qu'il
ait eu cette enquête récemment de l'
ocde le classement pisa qui compare les
ailes les performances des élèves de 15
ans dans 65 pays recule de la france
vous l'avez largement entendu au niveau
national tous les médias on en parlait
la france passe de la 22e à la 25e place
et surtout la discrimination frappe
particulièrement les élèves issus de
l'immigration la france est mauvaise
élève en matière de discriminations à
l'école les élèves
issus de l'immigration sont au moins
deux fois plus susceptibles de compter
parmi les élèves en difficulté voilà
pour la réalité du terrain on va faire
une petite pause avec ce micro trottoir
vous commentez régulièrement l'actualité
vous le savez dans ce journal quelles
sont les formes les plus importantes de
discrimination selon vous voici
quelques-unes de vos réponses
oui on a tellement c'est pas les vieux
je trouve que les vieux sont très mal
considéré parfois est ce qu'on dit c'est
pas très bien non plus faut reconnaître
mais il me semble qu'on s'occupe pas
beaucoup d'eux je pense au travail et
puis aussi dans l'unité du logement
aussi il ya des fois quand les gens ils
voient que c'est une autre personne
qu'une blanche aux canards ou des trucs
comme ça bah il saisit tallevende le
logement où ils disent qu'il est déjà
vendu que s'est passé ou les trucs comme
ça c'est peut-être le choix au travail
qui est peut-être pas tout à fait
logique parce qu'il ya des petits
maghrébins qui va le qui valent des
petits français au point de vue études
et tout ça les couleurs les couleurs de
peau des gens je pense que c'est celle
là moi la plus grande discrimination
basse est le fait des revenus qui sont
voilà où il ya des pauvres et des super
riches
on va dire voilà c'est puni par la loi 3
ans d'emprisonnement 45000 euros
d'amendé c'est la panne n'a évidemment
maximale mais oui c'est puni par la loi
c'est un délit effectivement c'est pour
ça donc la maison de justice s'associe
avec déclic théâtre il ya un contexte il
ya là la ville nouvelle
la communauté d'agglomération avec un
service politique de la ville et dans
les missions de la politique de la ville
il ya la lutte contre les
discriminations et ce sera probablement
renouvelée dans le futur contrat de
ville
donc comme la maison de justice est un
outil structurant du service politique
de la ville on s'engageait également là
dessus c'est comme ça en fait qui est
n'est ce pas ce partenariat et cette
envie de travailler ensemble donc il ya
un contexte et puis vraiment une envie
parce que évidemment moi ça me change de
mon travail du quotidien inquiets de
l'intérieur se voir des gens à confère
d'information juridique à des gens qui
ont des problèmes de dents dans tous les
domaines et là ça me permet d'aller au
contact des jeunes
et alors là boy délire de s'amuser puis
ensuite discuté là c'était les
collégiens un spectacle pour les plus
jeunes existent aussi
oui mon esprit mais oui oui on un
spectacle d'impro cette fois qui
s'appelle un pro mini qu'on a un petit
peu réorienter afin sire que c'est un
spectacle d'impro donc on peut y mettre
beaucoup de choses et ont donc on a une
formule un premier ni spécial
discrimination donc on oriente un petit
peu toutes les histoires
voilà vous épauler plus petit et pour
les enseignants qui veulent vous
cityzi bout s'il souhaite vous voir
intervenir dans leur établissement qui
nous appellent à déclic théâtre 01 30 55
08 21
c'est très bien le faire aussi je vais
juste rebondir c'est ce que tu dit
julien sur ce que je trouve intéressant
c'est qu'on est dans l'action et que
effectivement c'est pas une histoire
d'idéologie c'est pas une histoire de
c'est une histoire d'action de vraies
choses devraient de choses concrètes de
bain sidaction justice d'action c'est je
trouve ça vraiment important mais toi
c'est pas juste 17 soit parce que ma
chronique on pourrait simplement
recevoir les gens en consultation et
s'arrêter là il ya maintenant la l2 n'a
pas disparu la haute autorité de lutte
contre les discriminations et pour
l'égalité elle a fusionné sous
l'autorité du défenseur des droits qui
est dominique baudis il ya des délégués
du défenseur des droits qui sont chargés
des buts contre les discriminations qui
viennent notamment en maison de justice
donc on pourrait se dire ça suffit c'est
pas nécessaire d'aller faire la
prévention d'aller discuter auprès des
jeunes mais on se rend compte notamment
dans le domaine de l'emploi qui a à peu
près 42 % des personnes victimes de
discriminations qui n'en fait pas par
qui ne la dénonce pas dans un contexte
notamment de crise ou du hameau environ
dans son garçon de 7 ans gratuit pour
débloquer la parole faciliter la
discussion la parole que chacun puisse
hull a témoigné qui en touchant les
enfants je pense qu'on touche les
parents peut-être enfin on espère je
l'espère également merci à tous les deux
d'être venus ils ont parlé et puis si
vous souhaitez a sollicité à déclic
théâtre n'hésitez pas pour qu'il vienne
jouer cette pièce de théâtre aux
établissements directement nous parlions
discrimination c'est aujourd'hui le jour
de la cérémonie d hommage à nelson
mandela qui a lutté contre ces
discriminations toute sa vie justement
eric bouvron et comédien directeur
artistique du festival d'euros concours
et surtout sud africain il est né en
afrique du sud il y avait eu jusqu'à
l'âge de 23 ans dans son spectacle
africa mon pays arc-en-ciel
il rend hommage au leader sud africain
de la lutte contre l'apartheid nous
l'avons nous avons recueilli pardon son
témoignage était en vigueur au chantier
léger quand monsieur mahdia lesquels il
figure est devenu président il est
ambassadeur
si la femme a indiqué deux insisté alors
religieux disco qu'il a fait moi je ne
suis pas toujours très impressionné par
tous ces discours des politiciens
tandis que là il m'a ému et je sentais
qu'elle en parlait du coeur parce que
c'est un homme qui croyait jusqu'au bout
de sa mission
et j'avais vu en passant à côté de moi
que il était dans un élan il
fonctionnait pour vivre son pays
poussons tous ceux qui croyaient et donc
il est devenu toujours à une référence
une influence à mon port d'issan
montcalm et or comme on dit en anglais
pour moi voilà et je continue de faire
mon spectacle qui parle qui lui rend
hommage et de douala je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec mes collègues en afrique
du sud
en fait un peu le triomphe de mandela
construit sur la planète voilà et
maintenant tout le monde reprenait à
juste titre j'ai même écrit un petit
poème de cinq lignes levé vous et danser
pour mandela
l'espoir se trouve dans vos pas dans ces
tombes m'a dit tu as mal de la tienne
artistes soient créés à nation
multiculturelle avec les couleurs de la
tolérance curiosité et l'espoir
les valeurs de ton oeuvre dans le
transmettre on enseignera pour que
partout dans le monde que ce soit
politiques sportifs ou même au sein de
la famille ne seront plus en harmonie
avec notre monde dansait thomann des
nains
le téléthon en 2013 dans les yvelines ce
sont un million deux cent mille euros de
promesses de dons uniquement au 36 37 et
via internet c'est cent mille euros de
plus que l'an passé et sur le terrain
les records ont-ils été battus bonjour
tombé du caire vous êtes responsable du
secteur de versailles pour le téléthon
quel est le bilan alors des collectes
organisées sur le terrain par cette
fameuse force était fort ce téléthon
alors nous ne pouvons pas tirer
aujourd'hui véritablement un bilan parce
qu'il ya encore des tas d'informations
qui sont en train de remonter mais a
devancé vonn vous donner un chiffre
c'est pas possible cela étant la
tendance est excellente et pour moi qui
est qui m'occupe du téléthon depuis
bientôt une dizaine d'années le
l'ambiance le l'ensemble a été excellent
c'est une des meilleures années du
téléthon vous m'ayez le record en tout
cas les chiffres de l'an dernier seront
moins battrons nous battre nous pensons
les chiffres de l'an dernier et l'an
dernier pour le secteur yvelines c'était
456 milles euros
donc c'était yvelines est il venait sur
reset et c'était un très bon chiffre et
je pense qu'on va là on va le battre
alors comment vous expliquer ces bons
résultats et ses records qui vont être
qu'ils vont être battus sur le terrain
ces chiffres qui seront battus sur le
terrain alors que 36 37 au niveau
national les dons sont en baisse depuis
depuis deux ans mais écoutez d'abord au
36 37 ya aussi l'internet qui ment mais
je crois qu'il ya peut-être un effet
crise mais la crise n'est pas vraiment
le phénomène déclencheur la générosité
n'a rien à voir avec la crise les
quartiers les plus défavorisés de mon
coin sont les quartiers qui sont presque
les plus généreux donc c'est pas c'est
pas un problème je crois je crois
qu'aujourd'hui maintien de notre de
notre collecte c'est notamment dû au
fait que nous nous pouvons aujourd'hui
dire on approche des résultats on est
proche du médicament la fm qui est la
maison mère du téléthon l'afm et depuis
le mois de juin
autorisé à aller jusqu'aux médicaments
ce qui est extraordinaire
ça veut dire qu'il ya eu un progrès
fantastique et tout ça c'est du à qui
c'est dû aux gens aux donateurs les
sénateurs voit le russe bénévoles mais
oui et ça favorise le don effectivement
on va faire un petit détour par le
village d'accueil vous parliez de
l'ambiance cette année qui était encore
une fois est très très bonne non pardon
pour saint rémy les chevreuse qui était
village d'accueil cette année pour le
secteur yvelines est ses relais qui
suivent une calèche l'image est décalé
mais c'est cela aussi l'esprit du
téléthon pour cette 27e édition
saint rémy les chevreuse est devenu pour
la première fois village d'accueil une
vraie distinction pour les organisateurs
citent une organisation délicate il faut
bien bien coordonnées parce que c'est 30
heures d'affilée le téléthon donc 30
heures d'affilée et pour rassembler ces
der et un maximum de personnes il faut
faire plusieurs activités plusieurs
animations sur des lieux différents
donc c'est ce qui a été fait là cette
année est évidemment seulement de
beaucoup d'énergie
l'esprit téléthon c'est
chez répondre à une cause noble c'est
et dès la shem téléthon à combattre la
maladie et aider à trouver les bons
traitements par rapport à ces maladies
rares et neuromusculaires
mais c'est aussi proposer à la
population sur ce premier week-end de
décembre tous les ans de trouver des
temps cesti ch détendent échanges plus
de 30 associations solidaires c'était
autant de spectacles et d'animations
réparties sur toute la vallée de
chevreuse et 22 bénévoles pour encadrer
les actions cette bonne ambiance du
téléthon s'est retrouvé partons tous les
secteurs vous avez pu aller vous êtes
session versailles partout partout
versailles vélizy viroflay partout
partout une un enthousiasme keane qui ne
baisse pas et ça c'est absolument
merveilleux c'est merveilleux parce que
les gens comprennent de plus en plus que
s'ils sont pas là un tel laboratoire ne
pourra pas faire une recherche et une
recherche qui peut permettre même
maintenant d'imaginer de guérir des
maladies qui ne sont pas des maladies
rares qui sont même des modes et des
maladies les plus courantes comme par
exemple la macula avec kéké de la cécité
les prochains jours pour les bénévoles
sont consacrés au comptage encore et
encore la suite l'édition 2014
dès à présent vous annoncer alors c'est
alors d'abord un stop
excusez moi le foot rappeur mais d'abord
un comptage qui est extrêmement
rigoureux au centime près c'est très
rigoureux bon et on est en boucle ça à
fin janvier
et puis après faut commencer à se
reparler pour préparer le futur téléthon
qui va rentrer en accélération à partir
du mois de septembre mais vraiment en
accélération mais avant il ya beaucoup
de travail à faire pour contacter les
uns les autres et s'assurait que tout le
monde va repartir encore assuré une
belle édition comme celle-ci merci
tanguy vcard est revenue sur ce mail à
tous le tract auront le téléthon qui se
porte bien dans les yvelines vont nous
le disent
et le journal revient mercredi 18h
toujours en direct
je vous retrouve aussi tout au long de
cette soirée de mardi pour une nouvelle
édition de municipales 2014 je reçois
l'ump marc robert candidat à rambouillet
le ps didier fischer candidats à
coignières vous pouvez laisser vos
commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux
hashtag de 7,8 à cul